The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: We're
now at storyboard 19,
panel B. In the last
lecture, I mentioned
that we're going to be looking
at several special cases
with regard to the
metabolism of fatty acids.
The first special case concerns
the metabolism of fatty acids
that already
contain double bond.
You remember from last
time that a double bond
with a trans configuration
forms naturally
during beta oxidation.
In the special case we're
going to look at now,
the double bond has
a Cis configuration.
Fatty acids with
a Cis-double bond
typically come from membranes.
One of the ways
nature plasticizes
our membranes is to
make them more fluid
by putting in Cis-double
bonds that bend the fatty acid
molecule and reduce stacking.
Ultimately, this
reduction in stacking
results in a lowering of the
overall melting temperature
of that part of the membrane.
The example I'm going to
use is oleyl Coenzyme A.
This fatty acyl Coenzyme A
comes from Oleic acid, which
also has the shorthand
notation (18:1) delta 9.
That is, there is a double
bond nine carbons in
from the carboxylate.
The reaction I've
shown in panel B
goes through three
rounds of beta oxidation
resulting in a Cis delta
three enoyl Coenzyme A.
The enzyme oleyl
Coenzyme A isomerase
will then remove the acidic
hydrogen from the 2 carbon,
repositioning the
double bond, and then
putting that double bond into
trans configuration, which
is now amenable to further
hydration and beta oxidation.
Overall, the isomerase has
taken the Cis-double bond
and repositioned it to make it
a trans double bond that is now
able to undergo
further oxidation
by the classical beta
oxidation pathway.
Let's turn now to panel
C of storyboard 19.
The second special
case that I'd like
to deal with concerns the
way that we metabolize
fatty acids that have
an uneven, that is odd,
number of carbons in them.
One example would be the C15
fatty acid Pentadecanoic acid,
which we get from milk fat.
In this case, six rounds of
beta oxidation will release six
acetyl Coenzyme A's.
But note that we're left
with a 3 carbon residue,
or carboxylic acid called
propionyl Coenzyme A.
Nature doesn't like to
throw anything away.
It's going to take this
three-carbon molecule,
propionyl CoA,
that doesn't easily
integrate into any other
biochemical pathways.
Nature's going to
add a carbon to it,
hence making it into a
four-carbon molecule.
As we'll see, that
four-carbon molecule
will integrate seamlessly
into the TCA cycle.
The conversion of the
three-carbon compound
into a four-carbon
compound begins
with the enzyme propionyl
Coenzyme A carboxylase.
In a few minutes, we'll
look at the fine details
of how this enzyme works.
For now, however, what it
does is use the cofactor
biotin in order to introduce
a carbon dioxide, or CO2,
into the 2 carbon of the
propionyl Coenzyme A.
The 2 carbon is the middle
carbon of the propionyl group.
This is now a branched
molecule that's
called methylmalonyl Coenzyme A.
Next, the molecule is subjected
to a carbon chain rearrangement
that takes the branched
molecule and linearizes
it to form succinyl Coenzyme A.
Succinyl Coenzyme A will then
integrate directly
into the TCA cycle
to allow its carbons to be
metabolized fully to CO2.
In summary, nature
puts a CO2 into
the three-carbon propionyl CoA,
forming a four-carbon branch
structure.
Then, in an amazing
rearrangement
that we'll look at later,
the branched molecule
is made linear, forming
succinyl CoA, which
is a TCA cycle intermediate.
So the otherwise useless C-3
molecule, propionyl Coenzyme A
is converted to
something of value.
Lastly, let's turn
to panel D. I'm
going to deal more with the
details of this reaction
in a few minutes.
But for now, what
I'd like to say
is that there are many
sources of propionyl CoA,
not just from odd chain
fatty acids in the diet.
Secondly, the introduction of
succinate into the TCA cycle
results in an increase
in the amount of carbon
going through the TCA cycle.
That is, this is truly
an anapleurotic reaction.
This is a reaction
that we can use
to increase the overall
rate of carbon metabolism
in the TCA cycle.
We're now going to
turn to storyboard 20.
Let's look at panel
A. In the last lecture
on fatty acid metabolism, I
talked about propionyl CoA
carboxylase, which
uses biotin to add
a CO2 moiety to the middle
carbon of propionyl Coenzyme
A. This lecture is a chemical
interlude, in which we're going
to look at propionyl
CoA carboxylase
and several other carboxylases
that are used in biochemistry.
One of these is acetate
CoA carboxylase.
This carboxylase
puts the CO2 group
onto acetyl CoA to make malonyl
CoA, which is the precursor
to fatty acids during the fatty
acid biosynthesis reactions.
Let's also look at
panel B. We're also
going to be looking at
pyruvate carboxylase, which
adds a carbonyl group to the
pyruvic acid molecule in order
to make oxaloacetate.
This is one of the
anaplerotic enzymes that
can increase the quantity of
carbon going through the TCA
cycle.
That is, it facilitates
anapleurosis
in the biological system.
Let's now look at
storyboard 21, panel A. The
carboxylases all
use carbon dioxide
as their carboxylating reagent.
CO2 itself is not
very soluble in water,
so cells use carbonic
anhydrase in order
to hydrate it to
form carbonic acid.
The biotin carboxylase
subunit will then
phosphorylate the
carbonic acid in order
to form a chemically-reactive
intermediate
known as carbonyl phosphate
or carboxy phosphate.
Now, carbon dioxide by virtue
of its structure-- that is,
a carbon with two
electronegative oxygens pulling
on it--
is pre-activated for
nucleophilic attack.
And as I said a few
minutes ago, CO2
is just not present at
high enough concentration
in the cell for it to be
able to add effectively
to nucleophiles.
A nucleophile such as the
amide nitrogen of biotin
would be an example.
So what the cell does
is use ATP to make
carbonyl phosphate, which is
a very water-soluble molecule.
It's a very efficient delivery
vehicle for carbon dioxide
into the active
site of an enzyme.
Now let's look at panel
B. The biotin carboxylase
subunit of pyruvate
carboxylase has
a biotin cofactor at the end
of a 14-Angstrom-long swinging
arm.
This subunit of
the enzyme breaks
the bicarbonate phosphate bond
and releases carbon dioxide
in high concentration
in the active site.
Biotin on the swinging arm then
attacks the high concentration
of carbon dioxide in order
to become N-carboxy biotin
as shown in this figure.
The N-carboxy biotin takes
advantage of its swinging arm
to move away from the active
site at which it acquired
the CO2 and then
move to a second site
on the enzyme at which the arm
releases carbon dioxide, once
again at high concentration.
But this time CO2 is released
at high concentration
in the vicinity of the
substrate, pyruvate.
Pyruvate, in order to be a good
nucleophile to acquire the CO2,
probably exists as shown in the
figure as the pyruvate enolate.
Let me review panel
B at this point.
Overall, this
reaction has resulted
in putting a
carboxylic acid residue
on the 3-carbon of pyruvate.
And this results in the
formation of oxaloacetate.
Thus, activation of
pyruvate carboxylase
will result in taking
a molecule of pyruvate
and converting it
to oxaloacetate.
This anaplerotic reaction
gives the ability
to increase the volume
of carbon that's
cycling in the TCA
cycle, thus allowing
you to be able to increase their
overall rate of respiration.
And as I've said several
times in the past,
oxaloacetate is present at
rather limiting concentrations
within the mitochondrial matrix.
So this is a very useful
biochemical reaction.
At this point, let's
move on to story board 22
and look at panel A. Let me loop
back now and give some bigger
picture points with regard
to carboxylase chemistry.
Pyruvate carboxylase and the
other enzymes of this class
have two active sites.
One of them is the biotin
carboxylase domain,
where a biotin moiety covalently
attached to the enzyme
will acquire CO2.
Let's call this step 1
of the reaction scheme.
Once the biotin on
the swinging arm
has been N-carboxylated
as in step 1,
the N-carboxy biotin moves to
site 2, where the substrate is.
The second site is the
biotin transferase domain.
In the example I just used,
the substrate was pyruvate.
But it just as easily
could have been
another quote unquote
"carboxylation substrate,"
for example propionyl CoA.
In the case of pyruvate,
as we just saw,
it's the pyruvate enolate that
becomes carboxylated in site 2
in order to form the final
product oxaloacetate.
This carboxylation of substrate
is the second and final step
of the overall reaction.
Take a look at panel B. Now let
me give you a second example
of carboxylase chemistry.
In this case, our
substrate will acetyl
Coenzyme A. We're going to use
the same chemistry we described
a minute ago for
pyruvate, but in this case
it is another carboxylate--
acetyl CoA carboxylate--
that picks up the CO2 residue at
its carboxy transferase domain.
In step 2, which occurs in the
carboxy transferase domain,
the substrate acetyl CoA
picks up CO2 on its 2-carbon--
the one distal to the
Coenzyme A group--
to form the three-carbon
product malonyl Coenzyme A.
We'll see later that the
carbon dioxide that's
been added to acetyl
CoA to form malonyl CoA
is an excellent leaving group.
Malonyl CoA is the fundamental
precursor to all fatty acids
through the fatty acid
biosynthesis pathway.
Again, we'll see the details
of this reaction scheme
later, but keep in
mind now that this
is a biotin-requiring reaction,
just as the one we just looked
at with pyruvate carboxylase.
Let's look now a panel
C. My last example
of carboxylase chemistry
will be propionyl
Coenzyme A carboxylase.
I mentioned earlier that the
breakdown of odd chain number
fatty acids results
in the formation
of a 3-carbon linear fatty
acid called propionyl CoA.
I also said that
nature doesn't want
to waste any of the carbons.
What she is going to do is
add a carbon dioxide or a CO2
to the central carbon
of the propionyl group.
As well as fatty acids with
odd numbers of carbons,
certain amino acids--
such as isoleucine, methionine,
valine, and threonine,
for example--
also break down to
form propionyl CoA.
So what I'm going to
do now is describe
a fairly general
method of metabolism
that involves restructuring
of the carbon chain
subsequent to the
carboxylase reaction.
In this overall
reaction, a carboxylase
is going to carboxylate
the middle carbon
of the propionyl group.
Then, following the
carboxylase reaction,
there's going to be a
skeletal rearrangement
to form succinyl CoA, which
will then enter the TCA cycle.
As shown in the reaction
scheme, propionyl Coenzyme A
carboxylase carboxylates
propionyl CoA to form a very
specific stereoisomer,
(S)-methylmalonyl Coenzyme A.
Please note the position
of the carbonyl group
that's highlighted in blue.
This carboxylate
in blue is attached
to a methylene carbon that has
an inverted triangle on top
of it.
Epimerization about the
carbon with the triangle
results in the blue
carboxylate pointed down
the way I've drawn it.
The resulting epimer is
(R)-methylmalonyl Coenzyme A.
In the (R)-methylmalonyl
Coenzyme A molecule,
I put a little lasso around the
hydrogen atom at the methylene
moiety of the molecule.
I've also lassoed
an electron in some
of the atoms of the
Coenzyme A moiety.
A vitamin B12-dependent enzyme
called methylmalonyl Coenzyme
A mutase, which contains an
adenosylcobalamin functional
group, will now act
on this molecule.
In this enzyme, a
cobalt residue is
going to enable the formation
of an adenosyl radical.
Look at the book for
the detailed mechanism.
But for now, it's sufficient to
say that this adenosyl radical
is going to facilitate the
homolytic scission of the bond
between the carbon and hydrogen
of the (R)-methylmalonyl
Coenzyme A. That is, you're
going to get a free radical
formed at the carbon that has
the small blue o written over
it.
That molecule will
lose its hydrogen atom.
That hydrogen atom will
migrate to the carbon that
has the small blue triangle.
Coordinately, the carbon
with the small box
that's part of the
Coenzyme A carbonyl group
will migrate to the
position originally occupied
by the hydrogen
atom on the carbon
with the small o over it.
The skeletal re-arrangement
is shown here in panel C,
and it results in
a linearization
of the original
methylmalonyl Coenzyme A.
If we redraw it as
in the box, you'll
see that you form succinyl
Coenzyme A. Succinyl Coenzyme
A will then feed directly
into the TCA cycle.
This is an anaplerotic reaction.
That is, it will increase
the volume of carbon that's
rotating in the TCA cycle.
Overall, in the way of a review,
the three-carbon compound
propionyl Coenzyme A, by way
of the carboxylase reaction,
is converted to a four-carbon
branched molecule called
(S)-methylmalonyl Coenzyme
A. It's epimerization forms
the (R)-methylmalonyl
Coenzyme A,
which is the substrate
for a third enzyme,
methylmalonyl Coenzyme A
mutase, a vitamin B12 enzyme.
This enzyme catalyzes a free
radical-mediated rearrangement
of the side change.
Specifically, one
hydrogen and one
Coenzyme A functionality
switch positions.
This rearrangement
linearizes the molecule
forming, ultimately,
succinyl Coenzyme A, which
then flows into the TCA cycle.